alright man : over eighty back in the
house how's it going good man how are
you I'm good thanks for taking the time
to come back here and fill in the gaps a
little bit
always a pleasure my friend you know
being in the ritual podcast studio it's
like a second home love this place
it's been an interesting month for you
some high highs and some hiccups along
the way and I thought it the right thing
to do the wise thing to do to provide
you the opportunity to come in and fill
in the gaps and and you know provide us
with your perspective on the events that
have kind of unfolded over the last
month or so yes absolutely appreciate
for Doris man of course just for context
and so everyone kind of understands what
we're talking about let's provide a
little timeline so you came in well
first of all you did the Drake Passage
between December 9th and 25th yeah of
this of 92019 that like Christmastime
exactly I was in Australia I invited you
to come back on the podcast you came in
on January 18th we recorded the
conversation that you just listened to
and I planned to publish that podcast on
February 9th but on February second is
when National Geographic published this
article about you that we're going to
talk about and I made the decision at
that time to kind of put a pin in the
podcast and table it until I got you
know a sense of the lay of the land it
just didn't feel it felt like how do I
put that podcast up at that time it
would have been tone-deaf without really
understanding the terrain and also I
mean you know not in service to the
audience but also I you know not in
service to you as well make sense we
talked about it and in the wake of that
conversation then you published a
response to the Nat Geo article that was
on the 14th
we talked again the polar explorer
community has also issued their
perspective on this that went up a
couple days ago and let's talk about it
man yeah yeah no it's like you said
it's been it's been an interesting month
for sure you know I think when I was on
the podcast like you said January 18th
my book had come out On January 14th you
know poured my heart and soul into
writing this book which I'm so so deeply
proud of and certainly stand behind
every single word that I wrote and then
I'm literally walking my dog I think you
said February 2nd my mind it was
February 3rd but it's one of those days
yeah right around there I was walking my
dog Jack with my whole life Jenna back
at home in Jackson Hole and we had just
heard the news a few days earlier that
my book had hit the New York Times
bestsellers list you know kind of
obviously a proud moment for us and that
Friday I was going to be back at my
hometown bookstore in Portland Oregon
paulus books which most people know
about books even if you've never been to
Portland have kind of heard of that
bookstore and so is just looking forward
to you know being home walked on the
bookstore my entire life you know as a
kid and all of a sudden I'm going back
to address my hometown audience as a New
York Times bestselling author very
humbling and kind of proud moment and
then you know ping Google or you know
comes in and there's this National
Geographic article that is long-form
7,000 words which is you know takes you
a half-hour to read it or something like
that and you know it's um it's
incredibly scathing and what was the
most shocking for me is that it was just
widely widely inaccurate and you know as
a human being it's it's hurtful
obviously right so the article was
called the problem with calling over 80
yes and it it sets about sort of
deconstructing this narrative around
kind of what you've accomplished and and
and what it means and they have a
variety of arguments and I think it
would be good to kind of just walk our
walk our way through them and we should
say at the outset that there's nothing
in the article and and there's nobody
out there sort of saying like you didn't
do what you did like you you crossed
Antarctica 932 miles 54 days and a pound
slide like nobody's saying you didn't do
any like the feet stands right so it's
it's more about the story around the
feet and how it's been positioned and
and also how it's been your story has
been received
by the explorer community yeah yeah
absolutely you know we can definitely go
through that I think the kind of initial
obviously you know reading through the
article was it hits you know Google
Alerts and whatnot and it pops up you
know two paragraphs in the second
paragraph of the entire article gives
you kind of a sense of the level of
unethical journalism out there you know
you've got two paragraphs two quotes
from my book one from page fifty one
from page 214 conflated into one
singular message that were about
completely separate parts and so the
totality of the article kind of follows
the same methodology which is I was
never I was never properly interviewed
for this it was never fact checked I was
never contacted by a fact checker and
the completing quotes I mean it was a
shame overall but really kind of what it
boils down to and what kind of makes me
the most sad about this entire thing is
there's kind of this mainline premise
that I'm somehow taking something away
from this incredible Norwegian explorer
by the name of Fork Outland and so who
Borghi island is is norwegian explorer
who in 1996-1997
over the course of that antarctic season
so you know 20 years long before I you
know even knew about really exploration
in Antarctica the way I do now obviously
I was 10 11 years old he did this
crossing of Antarctica which is
absolutely extraordinary
he crossed not only the landmass of
Antarctica which is what I crossed 932
miles but he also crossed the ice
shelves so there's these ice shelf the
wrong eye shelf and the Ross Ice Shelf
and his entire journey was about 1,800
miles and you know one of the premises
of the article is that I never give him
enough credit or I haven't congratulated
him enough on his epic accomplishment I
don't speak about him which is just you
know factually inaccurate and untrue and
it's really a shame even you and I
actually on our podcast I think a year
ago talked about Bohr Gowland
and my admiration for him I I haven't
relisted that but I'm pretty certain
that you and I talked about actual year
ago even on this podcast and I've been a
vocal advocate what separates the two of
us and why they're different is that
there's you know a Le which is Antarctic
logistic and expeditions the people that
facilitate the logistics have a very
specific criteria
of what considers solo both Borg and I
were both solo so the same there what
constitutes unsupported so unsupported
means and it's very explicit on their
website it's not like somebody making up
its hand you know very explicit
unsupported means no use of resupplies
so no food or fuel or anything no Depot
so you're taking everything you can with
you hence why my sled start at 375
pounds and Borg as I believe was you
know over 400 pounds because he was
going even further distance but the kind
of distinction between the two of us is
something called unassisted which again
is very explicit on in our ecologist six
and expeditions website it's posted
everywhere and what that pertains to is
they consider an assisted expedition
something that uses more than just human
power to propel them and so in this
instance a kite is the main sort of wind
aid in this case in Borg island very
famously did this crossing using two
very large kites oh yeah - yes so this
is something that's I've actually come
to realize even going deeper into this
and it was never my desire to debunk him
but the article yes made it made it
sound like the the kite was of nominal
assistance I think I can't remember the
exact phraseology but it's something
along the lines of you know he pulled it
out from time to time and he kind of
jerry-rigged it on the spot and it was
it wasn't that beneficial but when you
look at the distances covered over the
number of days I mean he almost he did
almost double the distance that you did
yeah so he did about 1,800 miles thing
850 sixty-four days yeah
and I did 932 and 54 days and he talks
about it again what's interesting and
again it makes me sad it feels like you
know the journalists himself clearly
didn't read my book and I'll definitely
gonna read a page from it because it
talks about how I'm really admiring Borg
Allison in my own book in my own words
but also borghi Olson wrote a book that
has you know published in 1997 that I've
had a you know had a chance to have a
look at now recently actually and
there's photographs of this kite
actually these two kites one's 12 square
meters the other is 24 square meters the
big one he actually calls Big Boi and
talks about it you know over and over
again but then when he's quoted in the
article it says oh it's this
jerry-rigged thing
or he also says in a New York Times
op-ed that was written a year ago that
it was like a tiny square piece of cloth
that I pulled out from time to time now
National Geographic after I wrote a 16
page letter and response to this which
anyone can see link to my Instagram it's
very thorough it's not like
argumentative he said he said type of
thing it's just a very you know concise
almost not concise is 16 pages become
legal brief yeah I mean it is you must
have self writing that I mean that's
quite a comprehensive don't you know as
with most things do me and Jenna
we should say I mean there was a call
you know there was a that was
accompanied by a request that NatGeo
pull the article they've declined to
pull the article apparently they made a
few alterations right and so one of the
things that they have made as a
correction is this thing about the
jury-rigged kite they've actually said
you know we got that wrong this was a
manufactured kite and what they still I
guess have are getting wrong is that
it's not just one kite but it was
actually two large sails and these were
things like these photographs are in
Borga Allen's own book you know he talks
and as he should with great pride then
on a single day over the course of 15 or
16 hours he covered 226 kilometers which
is roughly 125 130 miles in a day in a
24 hour period a 15 hour period yeah so
we all slept in there hauling ass I mean
I'm sure there were days where he wasn't
moving very much at all but that's a
huge day I mean clearly you know the
kite played a large role and they're
just two different things what do you
like so why do you suspect then that
that Borghi is is one of the people
who's taking issue with your account of
this you know we'll get into that a
second but I think it's important to
note just like for this is that like you
know I'm pay they say in the article one
of the key premises does Colin does not
acknowledge Borg ascent right but on
page 49 of my own book this is my book
in my own words there couldn't be more
clear it says they're Norwegian
adventure at borghi Alan in many ways to
find the terrain of astonishing modern
Antarctic feats becoming the first
person across an article solo when he
traveled 1,800 miles alone in 63 days
from late 1996 to early 1997
not only did he cross the entire land
mass of Antarctica but he also crossed
the full Ron and
sighs shelfs from the ocean's edge
Alison's expedition which had deeply
inspired me was unsupported that he'd
hauled all his food and fuel with no
resupplies but importantly assisted in
that he used a parasite shoot like kite
called a para wing right harnessing the
wind to pull him across the ice and the
thing is I think the thing that's the
saddest part about all of this for me I
mean there's a number of things are sad
about it but like I think what Borg
Allison did was extraordinary
the day after I finished my crossing not
I didn't wait to write my book and put a
paragraph in there about there the day
after I finished my crossing it's
December 26 the day I finished and on
December 27 my Instagram post I'm still
sitting alone in my tent in Antarctica
I've had no contact with the outside
world other than like a you know brief
phone call with Jenna and my family I
write an Instagram post called standing
on the shoulders of giants which was a
very humble post that acknowledges Borka
Alison as well as many other pioneering
Antarctic explorers and saying hey like
you know I'm really proud of this thing
but there's no way I could have done
this without the inspiration from so
many people done extraordinary things on
this continent you know over time and so
I think there's a deep sadness for me
and even in this conversation you know
it's very clear to me what the different
distinction is between using a kite and
the fact that he went 226 kilometers in
a single day and that it wasn't just a
scrappy piece of cloth that he liked
jury-rigged it's a you know manufactured
thing whatever but like even in that my
purpose here is not to tear down or
asterisks somebody as extraordinary as
Ferguson my hope and doing any of this
is to spread positivity and inspiration
but of course I have to stand my ground
which is like as you said from the top
of this no one is debating I walk 932
miles by myself across the landmass of
Antarctica you know unsupported
unassisted by kites or dogs and you know
completed that and no one in human
history had ever done that specific
thing before some of the controversy
appears to stem from the fact that this
sort of southern you know the the final
chapter in the in the adventure was on
like this graded what's it called the
levirate yeah it's like they
characterize it as as a bit of a graded
road I mean
even in one of your Instagram post you
can kind of see that there's some
grading in there and this sense that
that that that on some level constitutes
assistance that you know may or may not
measure up to having a sale but
qualifies as you know something that
should have been put more in the
forefront yeah so I mean again I write
about it in my book it's called the
lever glacier is the actual at land mat
or the feature of the train but the
traverse that you're talking is called
the spot traverse it's an acronym for
the South Pole Overland Traverse and so
McMurdo Station which is on the coast
the US and military states or US
government stationed on the coast
resupplies the South Pole Station every
season by driving this like convoy up
there so it's funny the use of the word
Road is a little bit a bit of hyperbole
in that yes big trucks drive on this
section of Antarctica but it is frozen
ice and snow and the second Antarctica
blows it's you know the crazy wind that
it blows out there it's pretty quickly
blown over but yeah absolutely there's
there's some flagging out there they
have I never saw this vehicle I'm
starting the vehicles of the convoy
myself out there but certainly I saw
traces of you know the South Pole
overland traversed I you know there's a
photograph of me in during my crossing
then it I talked about it in my book the
point being is it's not something that
was like hidden from public view again I
write about it in my book the only
distinction here and the reason that's a
little bit disappointing is that
everyone in the polar community knew the
route I was doing when I left to do it
and it was acknowledged as being fairly
within the Antarctica logistics and
expeditions distinctions that the you
know quote-unquote South Pole over and
Traverse was not something that was
considered aid in their qualifications
of unassisted and unsupported even more
so which is really disappointing from
the National Geographic article is that
I was not the first person to attempt
this exact same goal using the levirate
glacier so there's a guy by the name of
Ben Saunders who the year before I set
off attempted across and he started a
slightly different spot so the front
half of his was about seventy miles
longer in duration
to reach the South Pole but his rent
ended route from the South Pole to
complete what he was calling the first
unsupported unassisted crossing which in
my mind at a hundred percent would have
been in the mind of everyone else
following it would have been as well was
to go down the levirate glacier using
the South Pole overland traverse and
this is something that's widely in the
public domain
anyone in polar exploration would have
known this and the journalist says that
he interviewed 70 different experts in
polar history
he wrote 7,000 words about this and
fails to mention that the year before I
did this a very very highly respected
polar explorer by the name of Ben
Saunders was attempting the same thing
and somehow paints both me and let's be
honest captain Lew Rudd who also did the
exact same thing as me and unfortunately
I mean fortunately for him and of course
I don't want Lou's name to get drug
through the mud because I you know he's
a friend I think what he did was amazing
but Lou and I both did the exact same
thing and Lou is a very very highly
regarded polar explorer as well so it's
not as if like I came up with some
random thing that no one had thought
about I vetted this I talked to many
polar explorers I have you know emails
and links to people saying yeah that's a
great route yep that qualifies and all
those things are in my 16 page thing and
the fact that National Geographic wrote
this article is 7,000 words and fails to
you know conveniently not mention this
other very you know proud polar explorer
who is attempting the same thing on the
same route you know it kind of is just
to me very unfair treatment and I don't
really understand that yeah I mean well
Lou Lou Rudd declined to comment for the
piece as far as I could tell except he
did say one thing which was that and it
has to do with the the idea that you
were unable to be rescued if something
went wrong right and he he sort of said
look you know I've never said that you
know I was in that position and there
were all these other people who are
saying look he could have been you know
they could have landed a plane there or
they could have gotten some kind of
vehicle to you yeah if you ran into that
kind of trouble and then I know in your
response you've got text messages and
screen grabs of this and that kind of
state your case so explain to me what's
going on
yeah so again you know one of the other
to me very unfair pieces of the National
Geographic article is they try to make
the claim that getting picked up or
rescued is equivalent of calling an uber
which is just a really really nice thing
to say when you're talking about one of
the most most remote places in the world
so there's an article logistic and
expeditions the same company that
facilitates logistics the same company
that dropped me off the same company
that dropped Borg Allison off 20 years
before it's basically this one company
has somewhat of a monopoly on the
facilitation logistics in this part of
the world they have this plane it's
called a twin otter plane it's a small
little plane that's equipped with a ski
landing gear so imagine you probably
seen a float plane like land on water
it'd be like that but landing on ice and
snow as you can probably picture from
that it's pretty amazing that this plane
can land in all of these you know
hard-to-reach places now that becomes
nearly impossible if not impossible in
certain circumstances for example really
high winds that are creating whiteout so
Struga which is these huge kind of speed
bumps that are on the snow basically
this ice and snow formations that create
like endless you know fields of speed
bumps and so I was told by a number of
people including an article just to
connect traditions which I talked about
in my book which is that there were
certain areas of the continent
particularly this area called this
asteroid National Park which is kind of
a you know pet name for this area that
has really bad just roogie that rescue
in that area is you know very very very
unlikely to happen and not in any sort
of timeframe that would we don't be able
to make sense so you lose your tent in a
storm and they're saying all you can
call an uber and a plane lands it's like
no 50 mile-per-hour winds so spooky
everywhere like there's no plan landing
and you you know you mentioned that I
kind of make this they are kind of
making the case that I sort of you know
made up there's no rescue zones but this
is something that has been like widely
reported by all sorts of people
including borghi island like including
the guy that's like on one hand speaking
out against me it's like they're trying
to like talk out of both sides of mouth
I mean Bork Olson writes in a response
to a question in 2018 so it's not like
20 years ago this is very recently said
what would happen in certain areas of
the continent in terms of rescue and he
writes in some places rescues just hours
away other places on the route are
beyond rescue for example in
Shuji fields that stretch for several
hundred kilometers no plane can land
there and there's several other
quotations that have in my 16 page
article including one from Ben Saunders
so they conveniently left out of this
article felicity Aston who's an
incredible female british explorer who
was on the levirate glacier the same
part that they're talking about here and
she wrote now I felt stripped of she
writes us in her own book now I felt
stripped of all safety nets whatever
happened on this glacier there would be
nobody coming to rescue me no one there
to help and so what I'm reporting has
been reported by the same people who
have been on the same part in Antarctica
Ben Saunders and Felicity Ison
specifically on the levirate glacier
bore Gosselin of course on a slightly
different part of air Nordica but
talking about the challenging for plane
landings but even like furthermore you
know captain Lou Rudd and I when we were
initially supposed to be dropped off on
the Messner start which is where we
began our expedition both in the same
plane
our plane actually had to abort landing
us the very first time they tried to
attempt and landed us two days later
because there was not even a bad storm
but there was just low clouds in this
area and the plane dived down and tried
to land and pulled up dive down and try
men so I've actually been in a Twin
Otter plane in not even severe
conditions and the pilot looks over at
essence like we're flying back to the
base no can do and so it's not just like
this kind of made-up thing and I think
the thing that's probably the most
frustrating and this I guess obviously
was the pattern with this journalist
over and over I was never a properly and
why is it explained to me how why you're
not why you didn't get you know your say
in this article like did he not reach
out to you did he just decide that he
wanted to you know print it though
without getting your input or what what
went down yeah so I mean we'll
definitely talk about it so let me
finish that last that which is kind of
dovetails into that which is you know
specifically you know if you don't even
want to believe my quotations of the
quotations from all these different
explorers on this topic there is a
document the antarctica logistics and
expeditions sent to me on this exact
same thing it's a actual proper document
that they sent me and i sent this to the
journalist and they you know basically
and i don't have it right here actually
but it's on my 16 page thing and i have
a screen grab of sending it to the
journalists and it says
instace Trudy National Park and
paraphrasing beings to the exact quote
off strip paint plane landings are not
normally possible so literally there's a
document from the people who own and fly
the planes that is sent to me that I
sent to the journalist I have a screen
grab of him and I talking about this and
just instead he chooses to just like not
put this in the article at all and so
that I think goes into your question
which is I was never really formally
interviewed for this at all
the first time I ever heard from the
journalist was on a the afternoon I
believe it was of the 16th of January I
forget the exact date but I obviously
have it in my in my notes and he says
I'm researching this thing
it's publishing by end of business day
to day it was 1:00 p.m. on the East
Coast when I got this do you care to
comment on these four things or five
things in an email and basically like
you have an hour or two to respond to
this and I'm publishing this article and
the comments were the things he was
asking were you know somewhat alarming
because he was you know trying to say
certain people were contradicting me and
all its kind of stuff and I was very
confused but more than anything I was
confused that an article was you know
being researched or written and the only
first time I was hearing about it was
you know an hour or two under time
pressure and I'm on my book tour I'm a
middle of a bunch of events and stuff
like that and I'm actually about to
board a plane in Washington DC for the
West Coast and so I picked up the phone
and I called him and I said hey I just
got your email you know I've got a lot
to say on this topic would you like to
set up a formal interview to talk about
this long-form he's like no no no like
you know I don't just I want you to
comment on these two things and I was
like okay like I have documentation
including actually what we were just
talking about they're talking about the
no rescue zones and that al II you know
sent me these specifics things on this
topic and I send it to him while I'm
sitting on the you know on the plane and
you know I said but hey I'm happy you
know over and over again happy to set up
a forum on over here sounds like you
want to talk through all this like I'm
happy to do this no word never never set
up a formal interview and then the only
other time that I spoke to him I guess
he just chose not to publish the article
even though he's kind of pressuring me
that day was a couple weeks later and I
got a text message from him
said hey I've just got a quick question
for you and I wrote back hey I'm on my
book tour I have five minutes before my
next event but I can give you a quick
call and gave him a quick call and we
spoke for I think about four and a half
minutes as I'm walking into another
meeting and again he comes at me with a
very sort of aggressive line of
questioning and I said oh wow sounds
like you want to have a long-form
conversation about this I'm super happy
to schedule this let's schedule a
conversation you know we can get on my
schedule I'm in the middle of my book to
him like back to back a number of things
and again he declined to grant me a
formal interview for this and so you
know kind of when I look at those couple
of things it's like you know if you're
gonna write 7,000 word article about
somebody it seems like you probably want
to just you know so that he says he
interviewed 70 different people he says
you researched it for over three months
yet you know the things like the main
person the article he find it time to
talk to you I mean after he said he was
publishing it like the following day and
then a couple weeks went by did you just
think it went away or you know did you
you know like so many things are going
on in my own life so like it wasn't like
the thing I was thinking about every
second of every single day obviously I
get contacted by a different journalist
I'm always very cooperative and happy to
talk and it and it's still in this case
I'm very happy to sit down and have a
long-form formal interview and go
through all this but in that case you
know I he had said a couple of things
that he's commenting on I sent him
documentation that kind of disproved the
thing that he was asking I thought oh
maybe like oh he just had it wrong and
now he's seen the document which
obviously chose not to publish actually
but in my mind I was like oh well maybe
you know that's all cleared up great you
know we're good to go I'm gonna continue
on my life right and then clearly he had
you know a narrative that he wanted to
spin it's unfortunate that you know he
didn't give you the opportunity to speak
to him my sense is that on some level
this is a a reaction to you being a
relative newcomer to the Explorer
community it's a you know look it's a
subculture that's steeped in tradition
and I would imagine certain rules of
etiquette you kind of come up in a
certain way and you approached it from a
different tack and accelerated your
trajectory
word and perhaps that ruffles some
feathers or you didn't comport yourself
in a manner you know that that is
expected of somebody who kind of does
what you do in in either case it's
positioned you as somebody who's
incredibly accomplished but also kind of
an interloper to the community is that
is that fair or get what do you have
that yeah you you know I think there's
probably a generational difference if
you look at the penny like this like
come to me Conrad Anker is a friend of
mine yeah I mean like and he's you know
a legend you know what I mean and so
when I see that he's you know where he's
lining up on this it's like it's
disheartening to me because I'm friends
I'm afraid yeah I'm your friend yeah
like I you know it was important to me
to be able to have you come here and
tell your side of the story and you know
I'm not part of that community Toto do I
have friends in that community so no and
look I mean just like Borg Allison I
have the most respect in the world for
Conrad and him and I have actually been
messaging this week and we're talking I
think tomorrow is we have a scheduled
conversation and I said hey man like I
have all the respect in the world for
you you know let's talk this through and
he's been nothing but actually once I've
engaged in that level gentle and kind
and the way that I you know anticipate
him to because he really is you know
someone who I have a great deal of
respect for and his accomplishments as
well as his stewardship from the
environment things like that or
definitely worthy of applause and so you
know you know what this all boils down
to you know I'm not so sure what I do
know is you know is disappointing that
Nat Geo was not willing to you know
retract the entirety of the article but
the I know editor-in-chief did make very
clear when she responded she says Colin
you're 932 Mile crossing ran Arctica is
you know quote from her worthy of
respect and you followed all of the
regulations of the AOE guidelines that's
set forth at the time which is you know
again that's a little bit of polar
nuance but basically you followed all
the rules that you said you were going
to follow and so for me it's not as full
of resolution as I would like to see
because certainly this you know the
entirety and the the slanted buys this
article is left a negative taste in some
people's mouths I haven't kind of
you know looked at the entirety of the
thing but I think it is very telling to
at least have the editor-in-chief of
National Geographic say like hey like
we're gonna correct these things which
they made some Corrections and also you
know what you did is worthy of respect
and yes you're not like this horrible
human being you actually did follow all
the rules transparently the way that you
said they were now is there a debate
within the polar community at large you
know ex post facto of this whole thing
about how they might want to read you
know classify or characterize different
things like that's up for them like
that's up for them to debate and discuss
I know there's a lot of ongoing things
but like to vilify me for explicitly
following all of the rules you know
consulting with a number of polar
experts working with the company doing
something that the venerated captain Lou
Ruud who's you know
is worthy of praise and what he's done
and of course I talk about him long-form
in my book and all the you know all of
our relationship I was on the phone with
him last week like we're friends like he
also did the same thing as me he wasn't
doing there's like some crazy weird
thing he was doing like he looked at the
entirety of Antarctica he's been going
to America for a decade and decided this
was a worthy thing to attempt to do the
first solo unsupported unassisted
crossing of the landmass of Antarctica
and we and we both you know accomplished
that and I'm proud of our
accomplishments and I think that you
know for me the the lasting impression
one of the things that I think that as
possible was clear that the journalist
himself didn't you know read my book
given he didn't you know quote that I
was talking about Borg awesome but also
if you read my book which I know you
have and you blurb did and things like
that like I don't even the end of the
book not to give it away for listeners
but at the end of the book he survives
yes the end yeah I actually stopped the
last chapter ends a quarter mile from me
finishing this journey there's of course
an epilogue that has to like wrap up
some of the details but there's no part
in this book where I'm even actually
crossing the finish line ie beating my
chest I just did this amazing thing that
no one's ever done like the last chapter
of my book is called infinite love it is
about the inspiration that I gathered
the positive energy that I want to
spread in the world the
ripple effect of positivity and energy
and I've said this over and over and
I'll say it again here which is the best
thing and compliment anyone could ever
give me for writing this book is not wow
your accomplishments are extraordinary
you're better than this other polar
export like I don't care about any of
that what I care if someone puts this
book down and they're inspired to break
through the own boundaries in their own
life to go after their own impossible
first and that's really the essence of
this book and so it's sad to be somehow
mischaracterizes if I wrote some like
book that's like me pounding the chests
of the greatest whatever I walk 932
miles across Antarctica by myself it was
a deeply introspective journey I learned
a ton of things about myself and growing
and my really hope is to spread
inspiration and positivity to people all
around the world and it's a shame that
this this has come out to really
mischaracterize all of those things yeah
well two insights on that I mean the
first is that subcultures you know tend
to have you know rule books for how they
do things I alluded to that earlier like
in the open water swimming community you
know when Diana Nyad you know attempts
to swim from Cuba to Florida I think she
put her hand on the side of the boat you
know it's it's it's a little bit of
losing for details matter and it's
important to have standards and to
understand you know the lay of the land
so that everybody's clear about who's
first and all of that but sometimes we
lose the forest for the trees and to the
extent that this story has been
extrapolated upon to to you know kind of
undermine you know what you did which is
not in dispute is disheartening and I
think second to that is you know how
this article closes with a bit of a
character assassination you know and
I've known you for years I've seen you
in groups of people we did the 29 0:29
thing together so I've done like you
know it's not crossing Antarctica you
you know physically exert yourself in a
community of people and and I pay
attention to how people interact with
others and at no point like I think I
even I mean we did our pockets a little
while ago I'm pretty sure I said do you
like dude you're a nice affable guy but
but I know you're a killer because like
you don't do
you you don't accomplish what you've
accomplished without being you know you
know ferocious and you're you in your in
your healthy ambition to achieve your
goals but that doesn't mean that you're
an [ __ ] I've never seen you comport
yourself in that way and the examples
that are laid out in that article are
kind of strange because it shows you
like switching expeditions perhaps at
the last minute but because you're in
pursuit of a world record and you found
yourself with groups of people that are
there for vacation or for other purposes
like it just you guys were on different
tacks like it to me I look at that and I
was like well it makes sense like he's
he's trying to do this as quickly as
possible and he's with groups of people
that have other you know rationales for
what they're doing I could see how you
know perhaps some friction arose there
but you know I I've never seen any in
dish' and all the time you spend
together and it's quite a bit of you
being somebody who you know it's lashing
out at people and treating people you
know in you know in a not so nice way no
strain no no I appreciate that and
you're alluding to you know a North Pole
expedition I did in in 2016 and that's
exactly what happened it wasn't you know
necessarily a negative thing at all it
was just that we were some kind of
logistics lined up for me to be with
this family of people and then we got
stuck there because of the cracking of
the see isolate us for eight days and
all the sudden they weren't going to
complete the full expedition that I
needed to complete from my world record
and so you know we found an alternative
solution to that and you know what I
regard is a pretty affable way I'm still
friends with the two young British kids
I guess they're not so young anymore but
they're in the early 20s at the time was
five years ago
was the guys who were with their dad
yeah exactly exactly a family is a guy
you know in his - that has two kids I
mean they're you know grown kids 20 22
something like that but you know you
know I think to your greater point you
know which is you know that is that is
not my character you know am i a human
being who at times throughout my 30 you
know nearly 35 years on this planet has
you know gotten upset at some point or
lost my temper or you know I've hurt
someone's feelings I'm sure that's the
case and for all of every one of those
instances you know I'm deeply sorry
you know I'm a you know I'm a complete
human being
with good days and bad days and ups and
downs and all of the rest that we all go
through but in general I would say and I
appreciate you know your what you've
said and knowing me all these years is
that you know my orientation is towards
the positive my orientation is towards
uplifting other people my orientation
terms of writing this book again it's
not about me but it's about inspiring
other people to break through and I
think you know 29 29 is a great example
of that and what you know just talked
about it says you know this is event
where we actually explicitly in founding
the event say this is not a race this is
you against you and you and you against
yourself and you know you were there
with me when we're at you know at the
finish line and people are finishing you
know in tears and every single person
that's getting a hug from me a high-five
for me we're congratulating and
celebrating every single person's
success and to me that's really my
orientation towards the world I want to
see every single person achieve their
own personal goals their own personal
best and up with other people and I
think that in a time right now we're you
know we've got you know partisan
politics ripping apart the country we've
got so much divisive nough sand whatever
like I really orient towards you know
how can we bring people together how can
we unify even people that see different
perspectives on the world how can we
share and evolve in a way that is
uplifting and inspiring everyone and you
know the this entire situation that
we're discussing right here is sad to me
because in a time when we could be
focused on things like you know climate
change and uniting around really
positive outcomes in the world and
uplifting each other and celebrating so
many people's accomplishments it seems
like over the last month we've been
stuck you know debating the finer points
of nuance of you know who's better than
the other person and honestly you know
that's not really of a huge concern to
me I think everyone should be celebrated
for what they've done and we should move
together in a positive and United Way
all right ma'am well thank you for
elucidating thanks for having me
anything any final remarks you wanna
make or anything like that no I think
it's great I really appreciate it and
LaPorta the the the whole conversation
from a month ago and this one being put
up yeah well I'm glad we had the
opportunity to do this so thanks for
coming
all right man yeah peace
[Music]